Welcome back everyone this is my full marvel
what if episode 6 video what if Killmonger
rescued Tony Stark there's a whole bunch of
Easter eggs.
They finally started to tease the big multiverse
crossover so I'll explain how that's going
to work too.
If you're brand-new to the channel, be sure
to subscribe to get all the episodes it even
though we are getting on in the what if episodes.
There will be a season 2.
And it sounds as the gonna try and release
it next year careful for spoilers if you have
not see the episode yet will be talking about
everything.
Just turning the beginning and work our way
through shot by shot talk about moments and
Easter eggs starting with the episode title.
So like I said what if Killmonger rescue Tony
Stark the whole idea that Killmonger tries
a very different plan to take the throne of
Wakanda than he did during the original Black Panther Movie
This time Killmonger gets a huge upgrade his
plan is way bigger than it was in the Black
Panther movie, they start the episode with
the same watcher explainer in all the episodes
about how the multiverse works and how different
choices cause different nexus events leading
to further and further branching timelines
more and more alternate realities is a big
difference in this opening scene is that instead
the watcher silhouette showing up watching
the events of the original Iron Man movie
play out.
You can actually see his face in a way that
you couldn't in previous episodes is if he's
manifesting above the earth much more fully
than he has before.
So when each of the episodes he's just shown
himself a little bit more and a little bit
more it wasn't till episode for the doctor
strange supreme episode that he actually appeared
in interacted with one of the characters was
meant to be a pattern of increasing watcher
activity that will culminate in him helping
bring together the guardians of the multiverse
team the multiverse avengers team made up
of heroes from different universes that we
visited in each of the episodes.
Like I said this is basically the events of
the first Iron Man film.
It all plays out.
Mostly the same with a couple big twists obviously
but if you couldn't tell it's not Robert Downey
Jr playing Tony Stark some of the actors did
come back some of them did not so I'll point
out which of the big ones came back when we
see them pop up in the episode.
But just like in the first Iron Man movie.
He sees the stark tech bomb almost go off
except this time the nexus event is that Killmonger
who came up to the US military right out of
school saves them and takes him away from
the area before the 10 rings can capture him
and hold in ransom in obviously.
We learn later that this is him manipulating
events.
This whole time as part of his grand plan
to take the throne of Wakanda the scope of
his plan in this episode is way bigger than
it was in the Black Panther film the scene
is also important because we just saw the
shang chi movie in they explain the true history
of the MCU version of the Mandarin and they
revealed that he was behind the events of
the first Iron Man film.
So when the 10 rings hit his convoy originally
it was Wenwu's orders.
It was him trying to get his hands on stark
tech weaponry the Jericho missiles.
So in effect
Wenwu was responsible for Tony Stark becoming
Iron Man in the MCU.
Because if it would've been for Wenwu attacking
his convoy he would've never got into the
cave and that's the whole premise of the episode.
Because it is going to the cave.
He never becomes iron man this reality just
a cool connection to the shang chi movie when
the watcher shows us the original Iron Man
origin story from the infinity saga from the
sacred timeline version of events.
The main MCU universe.
You see that iconic scene of Iron Man banging
the hammer making the Mark one he's's heroes
are forged in darkness, not born.
That's also meant to be a sly reference to
Killmonger slowly becoming a hero of source
like an antihero forged in darkness because
the plan that he's orchestrating here is a
very dark plan was sort of get his own redemption
arc in later episodes when they had their
big guardians of the multiverse crossover
episodes when the watcher is doing that montage
of iron man's life of the original marvel
movies all the way through avengers endgame.
Like you see him snap the infinity gauntlet,
even though they didn't use Robert Downey
Jr is the voice of the what if version of
Tony Stark they did pull the audio from Avengers Endgame
So this is Robert Downey Jr's voice from Avengers
endgame for this particular scene where he
says and I am Iron Man snapping the gauntlet
sometimes in the what if series the reuse
clips and dialogue from the original marvel
movies is a just copy and paste them from
the original movies we get a very different
version of that press conference from the
original Iron Man movie when he gets rescued
from the cave.
This time he's honoring Killmonger and naming
him to his staff and Killmonger obviously
Alice obidiah stane revealing that he was
working with the 10 rings on the DL to get
rid of Tony Stark, so he never winds up becoming
iron monger in this timeline.
Even though Killmonger was lying about a lot
of things.
He wasn't lying about infiltrating the 10
rings in order to get all this information
Jon Favreau did come back to do the voice
of happy Hogan again.
Like he came back during the marvel zombies
episode, but Pepper Potts is not being played
by Gwyneth Paltrow even though she is a dead
ringer for Gwyneth Paltrow's voice you notice
Tony Stark speech during this is almost exact
reverse is it was during the original movie.
He says he's doubling down building bigger
batter weapons to fight back harder obviously
learning all the wrong lessons when happy
Hogan jokes that was supposed to be his promotion.
That's a reference to the original Iron Man
movies.
Because happy was eventually made head of
security for Stark industries Leslie bid did
come back to do the voice of Christine Everhart
for this cameo scene where they out obidiah
stane she kind of figures Killmonger's planned
out the same way that shuri and a lot of other
people like Pepper Potts kind of figure out
what Killmonger was doing the whole time her
questioning him about orchestrating events
of that he would be there to save Iron Man
like did you set all this up yourself is meant
to foreshadow a lot of the reveals later on
about him manipulating events, making it seem
like he was the hero this whole time.
The big party that they have to celebrate
after getting rid of obidiah stane is at his
original house before it was destroyed during
the events of Iron Man three.
Remember, this is all happening during the
year 2008 that's why a lot of people that
were dead later in the timeline are still
alive liking T'Chaka is still alive you notice
to all these scenes, especially later in the
episode to Iron Man is drinking constantly.
So he still a bit of an alcoholic in this
reality when he makes the joke about Maxim
cover models being similar to corporators
and terrorists.
That's also meant to be a sly reference to
black widow in Iron Man two when they had
all the pictures of her modeling on the covers
of those magazines as part of her deep cover,
but in this context though he's just joking
about Maxim cover models trying to have sex
with kings and missing Tony Stark basically
winds up giving Killmonger obidiah stane's
job is his new partner Pepper Potts obviously
kind of figures things out and they foreshadow
things by him making the Butch Cassidy Sundance
kid reference Pepper Potts like wait a minute,
they both died at the end of that movie foreshadowing
Tony Stark's death at the hands of Killmonger
at the end of the episode and possibly the
death of Killmonger eventually at the end
of the series.
Don Cheadle did come back to do the voice
of Rhodey who gives Pepper Potts all the details
on Killmonger's back story.
The same way the Everett Ross sort of gave
them all the details on his backstory during
the Black Panther movie.
But the funny thing here is that you remember
because the where we are in the timeline is
Don Cheadle doing a version of Terrence Howard's
Rhodey during the events of the first Iron Man film
It's the same effect that we got in what if
episode three for Mark Ruffalo was playing
the whole but it was the Edward Norton's version
of the whole during the events of the incredible hulk movie
Like the recast new actors playing the original
versions as if they been playing the characters.
This whole time.
And because the whole nexus event didn't happen
until he rescues Iron Man all of Killmonger's
backstory up to that point was the exact same
as it was in all the marvel movies.
With the exception of him going deep cover
inside the 10 rings.
I think so he creates all the same Iron Man
technology from the original iron man movies.
He just using it is very twisted darker way.
Like he shows in the Jericho missile that
he try to make a portable version of using
repulsors tech he still got that done the
robot from the first Iron Man film Killmonger
quotes Howard Stark and he's correct.
I think that the quote is from the first captain
America movie, they both bond over their dead
fathers and like is it because the MCU timeline
is most of the same right up until the nexus
point Killmonger's father still died in the
same way that he did during the Black Panther
movie killed by his brother, King T'Chaka
for trying to arm all the gangs with vibranium weapons
If you didn't realize when the Black Panther
movie originally came out Killmonger went
to MIT just like Iron Man Iron Man went to
MIT just that Iron Man graduated from MIT
when he was way way younger because is a genius
and I love the funny anime references Killmonger
reveals he's a giant weeb and he had plans
to create a version of a gundam but just couldn't
get it to work so Iron Man finish the job
with this is him manipulating Tony Stark into
creating all these gundam drones River this
is all part of his long con that he been orchestrating
this whole time is very similar to the iron
man two armor wars plot with the unmanned
stark tech drones the Justin Hammer created,
which itself is based on the original armor
wars storyline from the comics, during that
storyline Justin Hammer just get his hands
on stark tech using it to create a bunch of
his own armor robots so they adapted some
of that for the plot of Iron Man two Marvel
is currently making the live action armor
wars Disney plus series will see how they
change that just based on what's already happened
in the MCU will mostly be about Rhodey stopping
whoever gets their hands on all the stark
tech to create a bunch of their own armor
suits.
Maybe the bring Justin Hammer back for that
Tony Stark makes the gundam reference wealth
it doesn't work will have the world's most
expensive gundam replica but the anime reference
is actually a reference to something that
Michael be Jordan said in real life during
a Black Panther press conference when they
were promoting the original movie.
He said that he's a huge Anime fan.
If you didn't realize they actually based
Killmonger's costume on with the cheetahs
costume in the base his character on Vegeta
a little bit to that's why he wears the armor
vest looks like Vegeta's armor from Dragon
Ball Z in Dragon Ball super.
So now when you watch the Black Panther movie.
You'll never be able to un-see this is just
a reference Michael be Jordan said that his
favorite anime series of all time are Dragon
Ball Z, Attack on Titan, gundam wing, gundam
wing endless waltz and Naruto.
That version of the classic Iron Man montage
of him creating the mark to and Mark 3
from the first Iron Man film except this time
he's making Killmonger's gundam drones claiming
that they're going to use the Jarvis AI to
pilot them.
It was Paul bettany coming back to do the
voice of Jarvis during the episode.
He gets the same idea to create the classic
arc reactor to power them like is that he's
crating all the same Iron Man tech from the
movies.
He just using it much darker twisted ways.
But Killmonger plants the idea in his head
use vibranium as the element to power them
instead of the element from the iron man movies
was like a different version of him finishing
Howard Stark's idea for the new element that
was based on the space stone.
So if you didn't realize is actually pretty
cool Easter egg Iron Man has been powered
by infinity stone energy in the MCU.
This whole time because that new element that
he created is based on the infinity stones
they reference Captain America's vibranium
shield think it's too bad pops use the last
of it during the war, which was the story
that the wakandans told to the US forces the
time to hide the fact that they had a giant
meteorite of vibranium Killmonger whips out
his vibranium ring that his father passed
to him marking him as part of the Royal family
of Wakanda planting the idea that they can
go see Lucy's cloth who has a secret stash
of vibranium in obviously.
This gets into the plot for Avengers: Age
of Ultron they use Rhodey pull off the deal.
But this is basically them doing the Ultron
vibranium plot from age of Ultron in obviously
it's revealed the Killmonger manipulated events.
The whole time working with clause behind
the scenes so that he could kill Black Panther
and take T'challa out of the equation early
on Killmonger also encourages them to use
Rhodey is an intermediary from the US government
to purchase all the vibranium on the DL so
that he can make it look like Rhodey kill
Black Panther and because the war between
the US and Wakanda if he couldn't tell it
was Andy serkis who came back to do Ulysses
clause voice for the episode.
Like is that right out of Avengers: Age of
Ultron is the same scene of Ultron showing
up the bile the vibranium he does reference
that a single Dora milaje vibranium spear
cost him $10 million.
Just to give you an idea of how valuable vibranium
is around the world claw also references his
history with Tony Stark in the way they explain
this Killmonger had a Ulysses clause leak
the information about the deal going down
to the forces will conduct so that Black Panther
would show up so that he could kill Black
Panther using the special sonic weapon.
So that was the reason why Black Panther shows
up to stop the deal.
And it was Chadwick Boseman coming back to
the voice of this version of Black Panther
so that's why the scene at the end was so
powerful integrate scene between Chadwick
Boseman in Michael be Jordan after the events
of the Black Panther movie.
Because were in obviously never going to get
to see that happen again in real life, because
Chadwick Boseman passed away.
But Killmonger, winds up killing Rhodey using
that same burn it down logic that he had during
the Black Panther movie, then pins Black Panther's
death on him.
So that when the Dora milaje show up later
they find it and declare war on the United
States if he couldn't tell John Connie also
came back from the Black Panther movie to
do the voice of king to Chaka, he also came
back to do to Chaka in episode to for the
T'challa starlord story Tony Stark who was
Rhodey's closest friend figures out what Killmonger
did using Jarvis because this is a darker
version of Tony Stark he basically says he's
going to revenge kill Killmonger saying that
he used his royal vibranium ring to finish
this one drone but Killmonger is able to defeat
it using the vibranium spear then using that
to kill Tony.
This is also meant to reinforce the point
that T'challa makes at the end of the episode
when he saying the cure for suffering is not
more suffering.
This will not end well for you Eddie the Tony
Stark trying to kill Killmonger going super
dark did not end well for him as well.
So RIP Iron Man again.
This is the second time they killed a version
of Iron Man during the what if series.
He makes a tribal scarring mark on his body
to referencing it to represent Tony tribal
scarring is a thing in real life cultures
do it for different reasons Killmonger in
the MCU did it to mark all of his kills and
of course Pepper Potts figures out exactly
what he did.
Even though nobody believes her right away
thunderbolt Ross comes in declares war on
Wakanda in scissor to use funds from the patriot
act like billions and billions of dollars
to complete the drone Army.
So if you remember the first Iron Man movie
sort of skewered Bush era politics the war
in Iraq the war in Afghanistan, but because
this episode is like the reverse of that it
only reinforces all the bad things that they
were trying to admonish with the original
Iron Man movie, so it's more weapons more
war more killing darkest timeline Iron Man
movie, then Killmonger uses the same trick
to use Ulysses cloth to get into Wakanda that
he did during the first Black Panther movie
taking into the shield.
But then killing him and using his body to
get into the throne room shuri figures and
out from the start sort of foreshadowing the
big twist with her at the end of the episode,
but because came to Chaka still so much grief
over killing his brother back during the 90s
he sort of taken in by Killmonger like oh
you have your father's eyes.
So Killmonger displays is this whole situation
this battle with the drones.
As if he's on their side wind help them defeat
the American Army a coy a gets a couple lines
and it is denied career coming back to do
her voice.
Just like she did during the marvel zombies
episode last week in their whole plan here
for defeating the drone Army is meant to be
almost exact same plan that they use during
avengers infinity war with the outriders letting
them through the shield to make it easier
to pick them off the one big change though
is that leaving the will Condon army is Black Panther's mother.
It was Angela Bassett who came back to do
her voice.
She hasn't done any big action scenes in the
live action marvel movies yet.
Maybe they'll change that in Black Panther
to but you have to remember that she would've
also received exact same training that all
the Dora milaje did when she was growing up,
even though she is a little bit older than
someone like a coy a she just as bad as a
fighter is all the rest of them Killmonger
manipulates events using the backup transmitter
to reactivate the drones after they disconnect
them shuri also figures this out to like why
would Tony Stark create a backup transmitter
that does make any sense is only meant to
be like a 30 minute episodes obviously that
can a blows of this plot pretty quickly the
because this is meant to be a darker version
of the original MCU timeline and they have
the infinity war battle instead of T'challa
doing the big Wakanda forever line when they
charge and it winds up being Killmonger who
charges in with the vibranium spear it is
to like it was too easy for them to take down
the drones you have to remember the Killmonger
was responsible for programming all the drones.
So think he engineered their programming so
they would be easy to take down just making
it easier for him to pull off his plan to
come off as a hero said everyone was see him
taking the drone sound like oh you're such
a hero to Wakanda that after the battle notice
here when is looking out over the landscape
Wakanda the watcher appears in a kind of looks
like he's getting ready to cry like the watcher
is super sad here.
He doesn't have any speaking lies he's kind
of watching it in sadness and Killmonger manipulates
Kang T'Chaka into believing in his plan to
arm the rest of the descendents of Wakanda
other Africans living all over the world.
Remember, this was the whole reason why came
T'Chaka killed his brother back in the 90s
it even though his plan successful and now
it sound like they're going to go around and
conquer the rest the world Wakanda will conquer
the rest the world and shuri, winds up figuring
all this out T'Chaka winds up naming Killmonger
the new Black Panther in the heir to the throne.
But this time when he goes into the ancestral
plane instead of talking to his father.
Like he did during the Black Panther movie.
Because they had Chadwick Boseman for the
episode.
The apathy wanted to have this Chadwick Boseman
Michael B. Jordan scene bespeaks the T'challa
spirit who gives him the moral message of
the episode.
Just letting them know that the cure for violence
and suffering is not more violence and suffering
saying that this is all get to catch up with
him, eventually.
And when he says on multiple planes of existence.
This is also kind of meant to foreshadow the
big multiverse crossover with the guardians
of the multiverse is coming up in the future
episode as well as shuri working with Pepper
Potts and Stark industries to try and stop
the war like things will catch up with him
in this reality.
But also in another reality when all the different
universe characters start crossing over, he
winds up wearing the same golden version of
the new Black Panther costume that he wore
the Black Panther movie the back in the United
States this poster of Tony Stark references
the avengers thunderbolt Ross also says the
words escalating claiming that he wants the
blast Wakanda off the map and I can go down
that way it like it's and shuri breaks into
Stark headquarters to team up with Pepper
Potts.
Revealing how Killmonger manipulated the whole
situation.
Claiming that they're going to team up to
stop him and stop the war.
If you remember in the earlier what if trailers.
There's footage of Pepper Potts and shuri
fighting together in the episode that we have
not seen yet.
Which I think the payoff when all the different
universe characters start crossing over with each other.
I don't know exactly which episode that's
going to be.
But we only have three episodes left now,
so it's can be happening pretty soon and when
the watcher ends the episode with that speech
about how heroes are never really gone they
live forever as to the ones they inspire to
carry on the fight what he means when he says
that is that heroes live on forever as symbols
but you could also think of it is a sly reference
to Black Panther's quote about death only
being the beginning in the ancestral plane
is also a lot more impactful statement when
you consider Chadwick Boseman passing away
in real life in trying to inspire people with
his performances Black Panther but if you
spotted any other big Easter eggs in the episode
that I didn't talk about during the video
just right them below in the comments.
Mostly a mishmash of all the iron man movies.
The plots of the avengers movies through age
of Ultron and avengers infinity war as well
as a version of the Black Panther movie, we
sought to meet party Thor in a couple the
other characters and they start crossing over,
so I'm assuming party Thor might be episode
seven next week.
We just got that brand-new trailer for the
Hawkeye series, which will be doing episode
videos for that will be the next big marvel
Disney plus series after what if ends you
can click here for my full trailer breakdown
of that and you can click here for all my
what if episode videos thank you so much for
watching everyone stay safe
and I'll see in the next video!